Hello You Tube, this is Bozidar Djelic, Deputy
Prime Minister of Serbian Minister of Science.
Many open questions today in Davos. I pick
one. And that to recognize that over the last
decade the growth or trade and the increase
in investments in particular towards emerging
countries have been very important factors
in promoting democracy, social cohesion, and
also taking a large number of people out of
poverty. That's something that happened too
largely in Serbia as well. Of course starting
form a role base indefinitely working that
restation today. The question has raised whether
we can continue trading and having this increase
in investment. Today and in the past few days,
we have heard from leaders of the major countries.
Many ideas of how to take us out of this difficult
spot. It's hardening to hear the leaders of
Europe, leaders of India, leaders of Russia,
China and many other countries say that they
are ready to do their part to promote economic
growth. But the question is raised, how are
we going to be able to promote social cohesion
and the degree of strengthening an institutional
democracy with a smaller pie of investments.
And should we avoid being trapped into zero
someday or it everybody trying to out do or
to out compete or to dump in particular socially
on the neighbor. We believe, an I'll tell
you from the vantage point of which in Europe,
that a solution is possible as long as big
blocks that have appeared over the last decade
work together to make sure that there is no
medium protectionism, to make sure that the
door around is closed in the debate. And above
all to make sure that we find win win solutions
an the idea is not to close factories in Germany
to open them in emerging europe or to do the
same thing in other countries. So more consumption
in china and other emerging nations. And then
making sure that we continue trading together.
One of the more important things where we
need to provided more mobility but aldo find
common agreement is on tolerance. The demographic
situation in the world is such that rich countries,
medium people, and the one type of people
that they need most is educated people. But
then those larger countries end up absorbing
entire spots of elites from emerging countries.
There will be no development in those countries.
And at the end of the day, not enough consumption
to support the rich ones. So let's make sure
that in the forth coming world of tolerance,
we also find common language the way that
we need to find in trade and investments.
They should not be worked out, they're should
be cooperation to make sure that the portions
are done the proper way all around the world.
They really would be better off that way.
And that's the message coming from Bozidar
today.